only through weathering obstacles
and grappling with difficulties and you
know
making mistakes that we truly learn who
we are
and as a consequence grow
hey it's ryan holiday welcome to another
episode of the daily stoke podcast
my guest today is one of my favorite
people in the whole world
rich roll endurance athlete vegan
best-selling author
amazing podcaster i've had an amazing
time some of the longest best
conversations
i've ever had in my life with rich roll
over the years at his
amazing house in california
unfortunately we didn't get to do that
one at his place we had to do it
remotely
which you're seeing right now or you're
listening right now
but rich has a new book out called
voicing change and it's sort of a
best of greatest hits coffee table book
built around
the podcast i contributed a special
essay to it a bunch of awesome people i
know did as well
anytime rich does something you know
it's going to be thoughtful you know
it's going to be wise
you know it's going to give you a
different perspective on things and i
think most of all
it's going to be really inspiring a
couple years ago
i was teasing uh rich on instagram
uh like i worked out early and i said
take that ritual he proceeded to i think
swim
3 600 yards three times further than i
had swum
uh just to rub it in my face ritual is a
machine
uh he was the first person to do an iron
man on consecutive days
of every single one of the hawaiian
islands and he did it as a vegan
which is just incredible if you know
anything about endurance athletes
he's really thoughtful uh he's he's
always
compassionate always makes me think his
father as it happens is
also an amazing writer he wrote a
brilliant book about
george marshall which i've recommended
on the reading list newsletter so check
that out as well
rituals first book finding ultra is a
long time favorite of mine as well
took a bunch of notes on it he's a great
guy so rich and i talk about
creating change not so much in the
political sense but
in oneself in one's own life as has the
stoics say
epictetus quote socrates he says some
people delight in improving their farm i
delight improving
myself and i think that's really where
change comes from
and that's where i think rich is coming
from in this new book so you can check
out that new book at richroll.com you
can check out the podcast there or
anywhere you get your podcast
you can also check out this on youtube
you can check out our interviews on
youtube as well and i'm gonna have
another episode with rich either before
or after this i'm not sure on the order
rich was nice enough to interview me for
la live talks uh and so that will be
coming soon we did an event for
uh lives of the stokes which was
supposed to be in person but again was
remote
so that's awesome and coming up as well
and i can't wait for you to listen to
this my interview with ritual
and coming soon ritual interviewing me
so how you holding up
how's it how's it been overall i would
say
that i'm better than most um you know i
get hit
with waves of you know
mild despair from time to time i don't
like not being able to travel
i don't like uh not being able to plan
adventures
the uncertainty of all of it and then
trying to
um parent two teenage daughters through
all of this
has definitely uh challenged
my dad tool kit yeah and
i feel like i have two sort of warning
signs that that uh
friends may be going off the deep end
number one is as i hear they've started
writing fiction
uh that's always something that it's
really getting mad if that's happening
and then and then the other is are they
growing a beard and so i
i just thought i'd check in yeah i uh i
i started growing this beard
the day that the nba cancelled its
season and protest well basically like
all right well i'm at home now
here's a here's a moment so let's do
this i'm now entering
jack dorsey rasputin territory or
territory i don't know how much longer i
can hang with this but uh
it's been kind of a fun little thing
i was i it actually hit me this morning
that
my son my youngest son has now
been a lot half of his life has been
spent
in some sort of quarantine pandemic
that's so crazy what is his awareness
around all of it i mean i mean obviously
the good news bad news there is like
it's half of his life but that means
he's only
you know 18 months old but um like
he wasn't walking at the beginning and
now he's walking so
it you know it's just it's sort of it's
it's so weird how long
eight months is and then also how short
it is and how much can happen
within eight months and when you're
young
time your relationship with time is
different yes
and you know weeks and months can feel
like years i have a 13 year old daughter
and i think all the time about how this
is impacting her i check in with her
you know constantly but i can't help but
wonder five years from now 10 years from
now how this experience is gonna
impact an entire generation of young
people and how they
interface with the world yeah my wife
was saying something she was like um
they can't tell us that they're having a
hard time
because they're four and two you know
they don't actually know that they're
having a hard time
even though they obviously are yeah well
my teenage daughters
i figured i could tell you yeah they're
not afraid
to let me know how they're doing
although i was talking to a college
basketball coach and he was saying
like uh he was like you know how do i
get them to understand
whatever we were going back and forth
about it and i was like you gotta
understand like i think it only been
like three four months of it at this
point
at this point but it was like even this
like three or four months was like
two percent of their entire life like if
you're a college basketball player right
now
to take like like a four months off or
whatever
it had been at that time that's to to
as you get older you get more and more
comfortable
dealing with large amounts of time
because you have
large amounts of time like it wasn't now
that i have a four-year-old like
other than college i really haven't done
very many things
that lasted four years you know like you
it's sort of i think you but as you get
older you have a better understanding of
time but the younger you are
the harder it is to wrap your head
around
how long this has gone on yeah 100
100 i mean i can't fathom the experience
of
the college athlete where their whole
life is
you know in this funnel uh to this
moment
and then it gets pulled out from
underneath them and and there's just
nothing you can do about it like the
sense of
powerlessness and the lack of control
over your own personal destiny destiny
is you know unprecedented in our in our
lifetimes and i think the repercussions
of this are going to be
felt for decades to come in what way
you know we're not sure right now but
certainly
um it's profound for so many people and
and don't you think
don't you think the real like it's like
we always underestimate the consequences
of things in a lot in the long term
i feel like what we're going to really
have trouble wrapping our heads around
as we go forward
is like how how does a generation
go through the world having been so
utterly and completely failed
uh on from a moral and
from a leadership standpoint right so
like let's say you're a college
uh athlete and and college athletics as
you know we're already
morally complex ethically fraught
it's a complicated messed up world that
you're lucky to get out a lot
out of alive and then how do you add to
that like something like
the big ten looking at the data
cancelling
then seeing other people do it
and then uh getting pressure and then
deciding to reverse course
and then obviously it's i mean look at
all the kids who've gotten sick since
it's like how are those kids to
understand what leadership looks like
going forward when they have been so
they've seen such a lack of leadership
in all facets of life in the last eight
months
yeah i mean i think that's a great point
i think that
we've never seen this level of distrust
in our institutions and disappointment
in
the leadership uh and what does that
mean
going forward with a whole generation of
people that don't have
the kind of relationship to democratic
institutionalism that we do and how does
that
then play out in terms of not only
government but
corporate structure and just culture at
large
i think it's it's massive it would be
interesting to look back
into the historical record and track
what the generation of young people
who survived the 1918 pandemic ended up
doing and how
you know how that kind of informed how
they lived their lives
although i i was thinking about the
history too as i remember i listened to
your episode with your dad
and he was talking about how it was the
aftermath of watergate that sent him to
washington
and sort of shaped his understanding of
the law and so maybe
maybe the the potential silver lining in
all this
is that from this colossal failure of
leadership
and moral leadership and just
incompetence across the board i think
you can say that
a politically um what will come out of
it
is a strong sense of like hey nobody's
coming to save us
uh this is gonna be like
a real like i was looking at the um
the super spreader event at the white
house and again i think you look at this
non-politically
my the one the one one of the things
that bothered me the most about it
was actually not just the lack of mass
and the lack of precautions and the
arrogance and all that
but it was how old everyone was do you
know what i mean
it was just like like it was dangerous
and then you add on top of this that
most of these people should have retired
a very long time ago
and and so maybe one of the upsides of
of all this is that
a new generation of of leaders steps
forward into the
well certainly i've never seen this
level of active
activism in young people um you know i
was too young in the 60s
uh to have any relationship with what
that must have been like
but you know i can just speak from
personal experience having a 13 year old
daughter and how
plugged in she is to the issues of the
day
um and i think we're seeing that you
know
across the board social media has been a
tool in that regard
as much as it is you know a distraction
and you know kind of a
a dumpster fire but we are seeing a
level of engagement with young people
uh at levels i've never seen before in
my life and i do think that that is that
is a good thing
there's a sense of it's our time now you
know we're frustrated
this has been you know screwed up to you
know an extent that is completely
unfair and you know we're gonna now
step in and take the reins and i think
that that is
that's what history is and um
i think that that's a good thing and
that we should welcome that as i was
curious with the new book
when you're talking about change are you
thinking
that kind of change are you thinking
internal change or is it both
it's both but i think all change begins
with the self
yeah perking to you know traditions
eastern
that you know the change you want to see
in the world begins with your
relationship with yourself and i think
when we start from that place and try to
you know perfect that so that we we can
become
the best version of of who we are and
and you know the most fully expressed
authentic
grounded capable individual then
we are able to see the world more
clearly through you know a more
objective lens
and we we become better you know better
partners better neighbors better
servants and and better
citizens i was curious what do you it's
been a weird thing like because you and
i both know so many people in the health
and wellness space or the sort of
self-improvement space
is it been interesting for you to sort
of watch either from afar your
conversations with them like sort of
how they've they've dealt with the last
eight months because
i've sort of seen people go in a couple
different directions
yeah we've talked about this a little
bit i find this to be
utterly fascinating you know the health
and wellness space
is something that i think germinated out
of a more
feminine sensibility kind of taking care
of yourself
and your kids and it's also born out of
you know an alternative perspective on
healthcare
like a a nod to you know traditions
ancient from ayurveda to
yoga you know all of these you know
breathing practices that wim hof talks
about
they all date back quite a long time and
the wellness space has been about
kind of reconnecting with a lot of those
traditions which is interesting and i
think there's a lot to be gleaned
you know from how those work in our
modern culture
but what we've seen over the last year
has been really interesting because
there's a there's a fracture within the
community and a certain contingent of
this community has gone
full conspiracy mode yeah
you could track that back like the
antecedent of that i think is
is the anti-vaccine like this distrust
of institutions
sure is part and parcel of an aspect of
the health and wellness space
has been kind of blown up and
exacerbated
mushroom clouding into you know all
kinds of
spurious theories about you know
everything from
dr fauci's relationship to bill gates to
5g to you name it and to see
a lot of you know friends of mine and
seemingly intelligent grounded
individuals
embrace ideas that
really aren't based in fact because of
this
predisposition or this kind of distrust
of of institutions in general
has been you know something i would have
never predicted but
now seems to make sense and i find
utterly fascinating
like the like you know to also say
you know to as a blanket statement
most of the health and wellness space
tends to lean
left but some of these ideas
that are now kind of percolating up
are ideas that are more sort of uh
endemic
to the alt-right movement and to see
that health and well
wellness space uh move towards the
alt-right and be
embraced by the alt-right and be
amplified by the alt-right
is is really kind of an interesting
cultural experiment that's unfolding
hey everyone i've i've talked about this
before but i don't drink coffee
i don't drink soda so when i need like a
jolt of energy i've
not always had the best options but
actually right before i recorded this
and
right before i'm about to do the virtual
talk i've got to do after this
i popped in a neuromint which are these
great mints that give you energy
and focus you know i think concentration
and energy are hard at any point but
even harder during months and months
of lockdowns from a pandemic neuromint
makes these awesome functional gums and
mints that help you better your mind
find the focus that's been eluding you
and do more with your day
it's got a blend of natural caffeine
balanced with l-theanine infused with b
vitamins and uh frankly just tastes like
a delicious peppermint
each piece got a half cup of coffee
worth of caffeine in there so it's just
enough to give you a boost but not
enough that you feel jittery or weird
after
so i pop one of these things in before i
do a phone call before i
jump on a talk before i've got to do
something important and it just gives me
a nice
little boost the l-theanine is found in
green tea so it kind of balances out the
caffeine so you don't get jittery
helps reduce stress energy focus without
jitters and the gums and mints help your
brain function
just go to get neuro.com to order your
energy and focus mints and gum
better your state of mind just go to get
nero.com
stoic or use promo code stoke to get 15
off all the products in their web store
that's g-e-t-n-e-u-r-o-dot-com
stoic or promo code stoic to get 15
off your order so what do you think it
is because it struck me sort of
maybe three possibilities or or more or
some combination therein but it's one
hey maybe these people aren't as smart
as you think they are
two these people are a lot more
mercenary than you think you are like
they're
they're looking at it algorithmically
and going hey
you know this will be better for my
audience and then the other
it struck me this is probably the more
sympathetic view
is that hey these people are under a lot
of stress
their business is suffering their life
is suffering maybe they've lost someone
and they're just sort of disoriented and
confused and have been
i don't know manipulated or or broken in
some way
and that's what's led them astray what
do you what's your read on it
i mean i think that there's a
combination of all of those things and
it's in
it's you know it's based on the
individual and their experience i mean i
to be certain you know there's a
contingent of the health and wellness
universe that understands that you know
when they
post something about you know the new
cure to disease acts or the new
supplement that's going to help you lose
belly fat
or you know increase your athletic
performance
that those types of social posts are
going to perform
better right world where the algorithm
you know favors stuff that is
um exclamatory in that regard and
they're going to get more traffic and
they're going to get more business and
they're going to get more
attention in our attention economy so
there's a built-in
uh incentive for people to spread that
kind of information
i also think that that um you know there
that that's kind of
probably most of what's going on right
your point of you know to your more
cynical point
you know i think there's certain
individuals that have
uh that perhaps aren't as mentally
balanced as
as they could be and there's a glee when
they get the kind of inten
attention that they're that they know
they're going to get when they post
something controversial
and then i think there's very well
intentioned people
who believe that what they're saying is
correct
because it's being um supported
by their uh their new silo
and i think you know it it bears
repeating
that you know we believe that we're less
manipulable
than than we actually are and you know
if you watch the social dilemma and i'm
sure you have and you're
well versed in all the things that
tristan harris talks about
you know these these tools have been um
weaponized to such an extent and we have
an algorithm
that you know is favoring pushing
messages
that lean towards that kind of
outrageous material and this isn't
this is this is you know this is a virus
much more
potent and dangerous in many ways than
the coronavirus because it's poisoning
our minds
it's making us uh incapable of finding
common ground with each other and it's
causing an utter and complete breakdown
in our ability to communicate with each
other and i think about that a lot and
i'm deeply
deeply concerned about it i was thinking
about that too there's a great marcus
aurelius quote which he
wrote during a plague where he says uh
there's there's two kinds of plagues
there's a plague that can affect your
character and a plague that can affect
your life
being that you know the plague of his
time could
could kill you but what was really
dangerous was what it could do to you as
a person and
and i feel like that we almost have
these sort of three viruses going on
right now we have
but four so you have the actual cova 19
virus which thankfully uh although it's
killed an
ungodly amount of people is is has a
relatively low death rate
uh and and seems mercifully to have
spared young people most of all
the exact opposite of the 1918 pandemic
but the the three i've been thinking
about him and thinking about writing it
i'd be
writing about it but curious what your
thoughts are so i'd say the number one
virus
is conspiratorial thinking so this is
pandemic this is bill gates
you know this is the all this nonsense
uh this is a
you know genetic weapon unleashed on us
by the chinese
uh then there's then there's the sort of
radical thinking or the uh the
that's not the right word but there
seems to be this also this like sort of
indifference right like you'd think if
you were someone who is like hey
this is a a virus given to us by the
chinese
uh also you'd be taking it very
seriously but somehow those
those are not the same right it's like
the anti-masters also believe it's a
bio uh a biological weapon right it's
like
those are but but you you have that you
have this sort of the callous
indifference
right that's like a different virus like
oh i don't want this to affect my life i
have a wedding that i have you know i
have a
i have a gender reveal that i want to
give so obviously i shouldn't be
affected so
so so first we have conspiratorial then
we have this sort of callus indifference
and then third i think that i've seen
this more commonly in good people that i
know
is more of a sort of a magical thinking
though like oh this will just magically
go away by the summer
or oh um well it's important
that it's important to me that my kids
go to school so i'm gonna send them to
school and obviously
will be exempted because it's important
to me you know what it like
and again i'm not making a statement on
whether you should or shouldn't send
your kids to school
but there seems to be a sort of fantasy
world that some people live in
where they're like oh this is true and
real
it just affects everybody but me and
the i the the party i'm throwing on a
private island with my friend so where
the
the event i'm hosting on the lawn of the
white house
yeah well i think a couple things i mean
first of all there's something
uniquely american about all of this sure
that perhaps we can trace back to our
tradition of rugged individualism and
you know don't tread on me
and all of that kind of stuff this idea
that
you know we're solely responsible for
our future
in this manifest destiny sort of way
and government's role is to get out of
the way so i can do what i want to do
right built into that is a lack of
you know kind of communitarianism or
sense of social responsibility
to think about how our actions are are
impacting our neighbors um that
you know i think is probably more
endemic to
a european culture so that's one thing
and i i think on top of that
you know it's important to say that
people are really afraid and people
really
are hurting and institutions have let us
down
and um people with power have
lied to us and tried to manipulate
us and i think all of that you know goes
into our psyche
and when we're in that panic state and
we're not sure how to move forward or
how we're going to pay the bills or if
i'm going to have a job
you know unless you have you know a
copious
set of tools or some experience with
personal development
or you know a lifetime immersed in
stoicism
chances are you're going to lash out and
you're going to look for
an enemy or somebody to be a
a receiver ship for your for your bile
and your frustration and
a virus doesn't really fit the bill we
can't see it it's invisible
so we need an individual so who's going
to be the bad guy here and i think that
creates an
environment um that you know gets played
out in the way that we're seeing it now
i think that that's maybe what struck me
as the most disappointing about some of
the people that you and i know are some
of the people in this space it's like
oh you don't you don't actually mean any
of this
right or or that you have talked about
it but you haven't actually internalized
it because
if you really understood what you're
saying right now
you would be aghast at the horrifying
implications
of either the remark or the the
decisions that you're making
and i think i i don't know it's it's
like it sort of struck me as like what's
the point
of all of this reading and writing and
watching these videos and working on
this
this self-improvement stuff if when
you are subjected to something like this
it makes you worse and not better
that's the thing right i mean that's
that's part of my my whole thing
with the whole self-help industry at
large
um and as somebody who's been you know
hosting a podcast for many years i'm now
on these lists with the publishing
houses so i got all the always in the
mail
and it's just unbelievable like every
week i'll get like a dozen self-help
books and right
get you kind of callous to all of it
you're like this is all
[ __ ] it's all right of course that's
not true
every single one of these books i'm sure
has wisdom in it that if applied is
going to make your life better but there
is this
gap between the information and
the application of the information and i
think there's this sense that if you're
reading these books that it's making you
better
and you're unconscious of the fact that
you're not actually practicing
any of the tools in the literature that
you're
consuming sure it's the same thing uh
it's the same thing when you
scroll through instagram or twitter and
you see a quote that inspires you and
you get this little rush and then you
feel like you've actually done something
when you actually haven't done anything
so how have you been thinking about this
in your own life i'm just sort of
curious like
what have you what how have you felt
like you've gotten better over the
the interim period and where do you feel
like you've
maybe fallen short that's a great
question i mean i think i i entered into
this
thinking i was incredibly well equipped
to navigate
all of it being you know fundamentally a
pretty introvert
introverted sure that has been the nice
part about it
it's like my dream is just to be left
alone and
not have anyone bother me so you know
the
the quieting down of you know all the
travel
and the emails and the obligations and
the phone calls
i was like this is gonna be great i can
sit in this container studio and i can
write and i can do my thing
and no one's gonna bug me and i don't
have to go to dinner parties and stuff
right but what i've realized you know
what are we in
month seven or eight of this whole thing
who knows
that even though that is my you know
my character i miss human interaction
you know i really do and and and it's
made me appreciate
that no matter how much you feel like
you're an island that
that it's important you know as a human
being
to have connection with other people in
the three-dimensional world so that's
been sort of a
you know a sobering revelation like
actually i need people in my life
um but i think i've i've done a pretty
good job
of you know practicing a principle that
i think is fundamental to stoicism but
also to the 12 steps this idea of
you know trying to control the
controllables and letting go
of of of the rest like detaching from
outcomes
divorcing emotionally divorcing myself
from expectations
around how things are going to turn out
and
you know i think that that that
principle is absolutely key
in keeping you grounded uh in an era in
which
you know we can't make plans and we
don't know what's going to happen
so i feel quite fit in that regard like
all of my
you know training over the years is is
working out well
but you know i have been throwing curve
balls as a parent you know i i help
parent
i have two step sons who are now 25 and
24.
they're amazing kids you know and
they've moved back home at the beginning
of quarantine and they've just been a
dream and
and you know helping to parent them into
adulthood
uh was a learning experience but it went
pretty smoothly
it did not prepare me for the
strange foreign genus of human being
called the teenage girl
right sure that's been you know very
destabilizing
trying to sort of surf the emotional
vicissitudes and the kind of
hormonal pangs of my daughters
has been an incredible teacher because i
will get
triggered and then i'll react and we'll
end up in you know some arguments and
it's you know just everything goes off
the rails
and then i have to regroup and assess
and try to do better the next time and
so that's why math is my 16 year old she
she really is my guru
right now because she's pushing me and
testing me in ways that
you know i've never been tested before
you said
you said no man is an island or whatever
have you actually read that poem
recently
no i haven't i'm going to read it to you
because i i read it last night to my son
i've been reading uh poems to my son
before bed
and i i honestly i feel like there's no
better poem for this moment it's only
like
one stanza so i'll do it it says no man
is an
island entire of himself every man is a
piece of the continent
a part of the main if a clod be washed
away by the sea
europe is the less as well as if a
promontory were
as well as if as well as any manner of
thy friends or of thine own were
any man's death diminishes me because i
am involved in mankind
and therefore never send to know for
whom the bell tolls
it tolls for thee that incredible that
is
i think i think our culture could use a
heavy dose of that right now
i feel like we're we're proceeding in a
way that is completely
contradictory to that idea right now i
would totally agree i mean i i think
that that line that hit me so if any
claude washes away the
the the hole is less i i think
nothing has saddened me more and sadden
me more when i've
seen people who are fans of my stuff so
let's call it self-identified stoics
expressing it
but some idea of like uh
most of these people would have died
anyway they were also
they were already old you know uh they
had pre-existing conditions of some you
know
any attempt to rationalize the immense
tragedy of what's happened i think of
all the things that have caused me to
lose my cool
it's not been not being able to travel
it's not been the money that i've lost
it's not been the opportunities that i
missed out on
it's watching regular human beings say
something
so shitty i think i think it's fear you
know i think people
are afraid and they're worried about how
they're going to get
theirs right and that's disappointing
it's like
we're all in this together we're all
suffering to some
extent some more than others but
that lashing out you know comes from
this
idea that we live in a zero-sum game
and the pie is limited and somebody else
is going to get my slice
and i i need to you know do something
about that
but because they're afraid you know and
i think
the only way it is upsetting and i i
share that with you
um but my practice has been to try to
you know go behind the you know what is
the layer behind that like
meeting that statement what is going on
with that individual that has put them
in that frame of mind and the more i can
listen more and and talk less and
understand that
you know every man is right from his
point of view i'm able to connect with a
little bit of
compassion and i do that selfish
selfishly because i just don't want to
walk around
angry and frustrated and resentful
because
that's you know denigrating the quality
of of my day
yeah i think even your idea that that's
coming from a place of fear
and worried about how they're going to
get theirs is itself
somewhat of a compassionate act and it i
mean i get it right it's like
i was thinking about this it's like um
it's very easy to say
you know somebody shouldn't be doing x y
or z
and then uh then you get a speaking
offer or you get
a really cool opportunity to go do
something with someone
and now now all of a sudden you're
having to
sacrifice something in a way that you
know it's very easy for you to say
other people should sacrifice but it's
hard to go
i'm going to miss out i was telling you
about a gig
i got offered and it was like i was like
look i'll do it if there's
rapid testing at the door if everyone
wears masks you know
these things and they were like they
came back and they said well we're not
going to do
like the testing but we'll pay you more
money and it was like
okay so it's good for me it's better for
me
but i have to it has to do the exact
opposite of what you're saying
we we can very naturally go through the
world zero-sum
and it's much harder to think okay i'm
i'm going to actually sacrifice
i'm not going to get something that's
good for me because i think it would be
bad for other people and there's a
there's a line from james stockton he
says the flip side of what's in it for
me
has to be i am my brother's keeper
and so you have to be able to think like
hey if i do what if everyone did what
i'm about to do what would the
implications of that be
yeah it's a perfect test case right for
you to
practice yes that you talk about and are
you going to be able to fulfill your
promise to yourself
and live that life right it's easy when
it's academic it's difficult when
they're dangling a big paycheck in front
of you
i was uh i was thinking more about this
health and wellness thing and i think
you and i have talked about it offline
but i thought it might be interesting to
talk about especially if your book is
about change
i feel like the other thing that i've
seen become really common
in our community or among people
who are we are mutual friends with as
well and i'm not talking about anyone
specific it's
a trend that i'm talking about but there
also seems to be this idea for all
the idea of sort of meditation and
wisdom
and learning and all of that it that
almost seems to have become a bit passe
with people
and now the magical uh way to insight
is with this psychedelic or that
psychedelic or this
psychedelic enhanced therapy or that one
curious what you think as a as a sober
guy what's your
reaction to that because it it tends to
be much more i think in your world of
the
sort of eastern stuff more than than my
world as well
yeah it's fascinating
uh you know i would say first and
foremost is somebody who's been in
recovery for a very long time i'm a
recovering alcoholic
when somebody tells me the you know
my spiritual evolution can be achieved
through a mind-altering substance
my immediate response is i'm all in on
that
sure exactly what my alcoholism wants
to feed itself right so there's a huge
part of me
that just wants to go explore that to
the hilt
but i know well enough that that is not
in my best interest
at the same time i acknowledge that
there's
amazing science being performed right
now
in the world of psychedelics they're
seeing uh
positive impacts on people's depression
and ptsd
etc so there is you know i i
i'm not going to dismiss it i'm just not
sure it's correct
for me and i think it's important for
myself
and for anybody who's listening to
understand that
that journey towards
self-connection that path to
self-actualization your own
personal evolution is not something that
can be
shortcut and you shouldn't be looking
for shortcuts it's only through
weathering obstacles and grappling with
difficulties
and you know making mistakes that we
truly
learn who we are and as a consequence
grow but it's tricky like i've got a
very good friend
somebody who's also been sober a very
long time who recently
went to one of these labs and
did a psilocybin experiment with
like the top scientist in this field
and he basically said there was before
and now there's after and i can't put in
words
how profound it was and you've got to do
this right and so
that rents a lot of space in my mind
this isn't somebody
who's you know um you know flying down
to
south america all the time to sit with
shamans like this is a you know this is
a guy who's been in like 12-step for
decades
so that messes me up and i'm still
you know i want to i want to approach it
from from a perspective
of first principles with a learner's
mind
so i haven't said absolutely no to it
but you know i'm not the guy who's going
to go on ayahuasca trips like yeah on my
own
journey and i just don't think that that
would be
in service to me and i also think not to
you know spin things too mystically but
when you're taking in
a really powerful mind-altering
substance
you've got to be really careful like if
you're
not if you're not emotionally fit that
can really
mess you up and i've seen it mess up a
lot of other people
and even though it's not you know
technically an addictive substance i
also have friends that
are doing it all the time like i i know
one guy who who does an ayahuasca trip
like
almost every week he did like 50
ayahuasca trips in a year and i'm like
you're not enlightened yet
right so what is this doing for you he
calls it
work right and i'm like well i'm i'm
going to pursue the work
in a different that in a different
manner yeah i think
it there's also this part that i think
it's a very human tendency
to think that enlightenment or wisdom is
a place that you arrive at
and so that it you can do a shortcut or
that you can
get it you know what i mean like the
idea that the there's this kind of work
and there's that kind of work
and and this is just a you know more
technologically
advanced form of it or something it
strikes me as maybe missing the point a
little bit as well like it's
it's supposed to take a long time and be
a lifelong
process because it's not a thing that
you get
right the idea that it can be purchased
is anathema to the very idea itself
yes the buddha who said something like
you know what he was asked
you know what happens if and when you
become an enlightened like chop wood you
know carry water then you
and what you chop wood and you carry
water like yeah it's not you don't
arrive
at the bodhi tree you continue to live
your life
and maybe maybe this is my your point
about sort of being
uh leery from a sober perspective i
think also my
my sort of cynicism kicks in where it's
like whenever i see
something become very trendy with a
group of people who have
also been on different bandwagons that
didn't work out i'm very suspicious
you know what i mean it's like a few
months ago
these were the same people telling us
polyamory was the future and then this
was the future and then this was the
future and
it's it reminds me of this thing seneca
talks about sort of people who flee from
place to place
looking for enlightenment or happiness
he says it's like the person who thinks
that flipping over their pillow
is going to finally make them
comfortable and let them
sleep and so i'm suspicious too
that like the people who are shouting
that this is the next big
thing a couple months ago or years ago
were convinced some other thing was the
next big thing
yeah in in in a it's called pulling a
geographic
and the geographic can be emotional or
mental
as you know as as well as physical the
idea that
you know i'm gonna find solace or the
answers that i see
or um you know peace of mind if i go to
this place or i adopt this habit
and what it overlooks is that you're
bringing yourself with you
baggage and your problem so it's not
your
geographic location or this new
you know bio hack that's gonna do the
trick fundamentally it's
you know the heavy lifting of really
facing yourself in the most objective
way possible
and you know grappling with your
character defects taking inventory you
know doing
all the all the work that's required so
that you can
look people in the eye and you know live
a life of
of integrity and purpose yeah i think
epicurus said thus
every man flees himself and i think that
you know
you can do it mentally figuratively or
you can do it literally but it's all
some form of the same escape
yeah i mean isn't that isn't that what
you know drug addiction is
in in certain respects like you're
running away from yourself
because you're so uncomfortable with who
you are
but it's also a bit of a spiritual
seeking thing because you're trying to
find answers you're trying to find
comfort you're doing it in a very
unhealthy way
but there is that component of like
trying to get out of yourself to find
a solution to what ails you yeah
it's like i empathize with it and then
i'm suspicious of it at the same time
[Music]
yeah it is it you know the older you get
you can you you have um more of a 10 000
foot view on all of these trends because
you've weathered
you know a lot of them and you've seen
them
come and go and you've seen the people
who have
um stayed true to what their core
philosophy is and then you see the
people that blow in the wind and align
themselves whatever the
whatever the new thing is and it goes
back to what we were talking about
originally which is
the difference between somebody who's
really carrying you know a message
that um that is meaningful versus the
person
who's trying to get the clicks or you
know trying to play
the you know the attention game yeah
it's like i i think
and maybe this is a silly way to think
about it but i sort of go
when in all have of history has someone
come back
and said i have the medical solution
to this spiritual or psychological
issue and it not
blown up horribly in our faces
yeah never right but the human mind is
wired
to desire that there's something about
that that's so compelling
and appealing and i think it it's also
important to point out
that all of these things that are
happening right now
are happening against a backdrop in
which
we've lost appreciation for
nuance right like we're in a black and
white
click bait world everybody has to align
their views with one particular
tribe and it's not okay to
you know have uh you know complex ideas
that span the spectrum
uh and and so those the the simpler
you know solutions are the ones that
people are going to gravitate
towards because not only can they
understand that but ultimately
um they're easier to co to
to communicate and that's why they're
getting traction
well and to go to your point earlier
about this sort of health and wellness
space it's like
if you built your brand your identity on
going hey
everyone is telling like in your case
it's uh
you know veganism it's like hey
everything you know the the food
industries are telling you about health
is totally wrong
um and and you're right in that case
like you have
a lot of evidence that hey we are being
deceived you know the truth is being
kept from us
it makes you a lot more susceptible to
think that you found a magical solution
or a hidden truth
or uncovered a secret that um
you know is being kept it's like when
leaders
when leadership uh in science and
in politics and in culture and in
spirituality
have so grievously failed us it drives
people to search
underground underground solutions to
these problems and i think that that's
part of where we are right now as well
yeah i mean i think you just you just
nailed it because
there there have been you know lies
propagated
and when you if you have a personal
experience where
you have somewhat of an epiphany about
that
does that not make you more susceptible
to
you know the next piece of information
um
being untruthful right and that's why
it's complicated
it's not black or white because there
you know there are
vested interests that
that profit from you being confused
about whether it's health and fitness or
politics or
or what have you but the trick is
trying to remain grounded and objective
enough so that you still become
a reliable uh you know barometer
of things that are true versus partisan
versus
complete outright you know un un
un-based
conspiracy theory i wanted to uh to talk
to you about the new book a little bit
um one what was walk me through the
decision to
to self-publish uh that that's uh
fascinating and interesting and
something i've been
kicking around a little bit myself too
this new book is called voicing change
and it's basically
you know wisdom and inspiration from the
podcast this podcast that i've been
doing for
over eight years now i've interviewed
550 plus people at this point spent
thousands of hours talking to people
you know you've been on four times i
think no i was just thinking i was just
doing the math as you were saying that
if you have 500 guests
i think each one of the episodes i've
done is almost two
or three hours it really is thousands of
hours that you spend in these
conversations
i mean an unbelievable amount of time
spent
you know in deep reflective conversation
with people that i respect people that i
want to
learn from and i wanted to be able to
canonize that a little bit to out of out
you know basically to
respect all these amazing individuals in
the time that they've gifted me but also
as a as a as a thank you to the audience
as well to have kind of a keepsake
and that's why it's in kind of a coffee
book form you can put it out on a table
it looks beautiful we have amazing
photographs your
display is wonderful and you can get an
essay so thank you for that
um so that you can read you know not
everybody listens to every episode they
can you know discover new people
or or or you know share it with their
friends and
you know i wanted to package it in a
really aesthetically pleasing
way with that of course it becomes an
expensive book
right it's photographs and and i just
thought this is not the kind of book
that a publisher is going to be able to
justify giving me the kind of advance
that i would
demand for something like this like
financially
it doesn't make a lot of sense for them
also
this is something that could turn into a
series like i could put one of these out
every single year and i just had a
cool experiment to try to do this
ourselves and control it
soup to nuts so um we're doing that we
created the whole thing in-house it is
you know
really i'm super proud of it it really
is a beautiful book
and we're selling it um exclusively
through our website and now we're
starting to
you know figure out what the challenges
with that are because we want to ship
globally but of course shipping is crazy
expensive and if we're not going to put
it on amazon who takes 40 percent of the
revenue
then you know we're basically placing
that
burden on the consumer who's so
acclimated to free shipping or
you know significantly reduced shipping
costs so now it becomes a customer
service thing like people are like you
got to be kidding me it costs 30
to ship this book and it's like well it
is what it is like you're glad that
we're not on amazon but
this is the true you know financial
picture of what it means to create a
product
and and control it yourself so we're in
the early stages of it so far i'm
you know i'm super thrilled and the idea
of you know having a book out
in the world where there isn't any kind
of
you know middlemen involved is pretty
cool but you do have to take
responsibility for all the little things
and you become aware of all the things
that the publisher
handles for you but ultimately
there is a different sense of
satisfaction with it
um we haven't even we start shipping on
november 10th but we've already broken
even on our first printing
and the idea that like you know years
from now you're not going to be making
one dollar
on your book but you're actually going
to be making you know what you should be
getting paid for your book that you
created
is is a cool thing so it is really
interesting
because i've been sort of experimenting
with some of that stuff with daily stoic
and it's like
one i think there's there's something
really important and powerful about like
actually figuring out how the whole
process works like you said from soup to
nuts like
actually understanding like oh these are
all the different phases of it i think
that's really interesting and then
yeah the economics are fascinating too
you're like so i was it's like okay so
i've sold roughly three million books
let's say that's 15 a book like
somebody made 45 million dollars but it
wasn't me
you know uh i i i mean not even close
right and you're like oh i see why
penguin random house has a building in
manhattan you know uh
and and and but you also realize as you
said
it's like oh there's a lot there was a
lot of
people taking care of stuff for me that
i was not aware of customer service
being the
most uh significant uh
of of those obstacles and of course
your book is actually underwriting a lot
of other books
yes penguin random house because it's
the rare book that breaks out
in that kind of way most books don't
earn out their advances
or are not profitable so for every
you know obstacles the way or daily
stoic there's
30 books that they have to you know pay
for so you're paying for
those people when i think anytime you
have a direct
connection with your audience that's
really powerful too like the idea even
that
it's like you sort of realize it's like
oh and i
i wrote the book then i sold it to a
publisher and then that publisher sold
it to in some cases a sub publisher
or who then sold it to a bookstore
who then sold it to a customer you're
like whoa there's a lot of
intermediaries between me and the
customer
and that's not to say that's the problem
with that is not just that
each one of those people is taking a
piece of it it's just you realize you're
very alienated
from the people that you're actually
making stuff for
and and i think the more connected you
are and that's what's so great about
podcasts is that like
it's like you and i are recording this
and sure it'll be edited by someone
but then it goes like directly to the
people who are hearing it
you know as these words are coming out
of my mouth and that's like a really
special thing
yeah it's super cool and powerful and
for somebody like yourself who has
such a vast audience and people that are
you know so loyal to
the things that you talk about it would
be interesting for you
to take a stab at a self-published book
to see what that
looks like what how um i think when
you're actually
asking somebody to buy something that's
the true test
of just how engaged that community is
and we're learning that we have a super
engaged community and it's making me
rethink like
well we can just do this ourselves
do we really need anybody else involved
here and that's not to say that
this was you know this book was a
massive undertaking it was a team of
people like
i'm able at this point to create some
infrastructure around this because
you're really running
a side business it's almost like a whole
new thing that you know requires a lot
of time and attention and for
somebody like yourself you have to
balance that against your sensibility
which is like i just want to write books
and move on to the next book and i'll
let all these other people handle that
and i'll
and i'll happily you know take that
bargain
so i'm not making 45 million but i'm
making you know
a good amount and i can just focus on
doing the thing that i do best
although when you express it that way it
doesn't sound like a great bargain
you make the 45 million all uh all
no but you probably won't like hearing
this as much but i did a leather-bound
edition
of uh uh the daily stoic so i went to my
publisher and said hey
should we do like a premium edition and
they were like like you said they were
like well that math doesn't really make
sense to us
we don't want to do an edition that's
going to sell a few thousand copies a
year
um that you know and i said well can i
just buy the rights back to this edition
of my own book and they said
sure and we did it it's like it's the
it's it was incredible to go like i made
this and i sold it directly to people
who wanted it
i didn't have to sell it for half price
to someone else who then marked it up 2x
it's like that's so inefficient and and
there's just something i think special
about making something
that's why platforms like etsy are
powerful that's why
um you know co-ops are cool anytime
you're like
directly going to the the audience it's
cool
and i think we're really still in the
infancy of all of this
right like we're you know both making a
living
you know essentially in certain respects
like by dent of
of the internet we're at the starting
gate of all of this like what does this
look like
in 10 years and sure it was in 20 years
and i think we're just going to see
more and more people realizing you know
to kind of
you know coin what james altucher talks
about all the time like this choose
yourself
economy where a lot of these gatekeepers
and middle people were starting to
realize like hey maybe we don't
need them as much as we thought that we
did and i think
psychologically that shifts your
perspective
to the creation process because you're
no longer
seeking permission you're just more
in that creative place of purity
but and i think this goes to the idea in
the book which is like
that requires some change it requires
one to undergo a certain change to be in
a position to do that especially if
up until this point your entire career
has been
getting permission working with
gatekeepers
uh you know doing it through the
traditional system
like to you have to go no i'm gonna
do it a totally different way yeah and
and there is no right or wrong i should
say like
i've done it the other way also and with
our first cookbook the plant power away
like we created that
in-house as well and the idea was we
were going to self-publish it
but at the last minute after it was
essentially done
i was like i gotta you know i have to
see yeah sure
test the market the value this and
and they valued it highly and we made
the decision to do it
the traditional way also because it was
my you know it was the first time my
wife's name was gonna end up on a book
and i just thought it would be better
to help legitimize her to go that route
initially
um rather than try to do it the other
way around and i'm glad
we did it that way we would have made
more money if we had self-published it
but that book would not have made its
way into the hands of as many people
which was
much more important to me at that time
yeah i like the idea too i think it's a
little bit more ancient you know it's
like part of
what our sort of mass culture has become
is like that you have to have a huge
audience
that you have to reach so many many many
people
the economy of scale is it works
but it actually doesn't work that well
for the individual right because it's
sort of a winner take
all kind of a thing the idea of like hey
we broke even on this book selling
probably you probably only had to sell a
few hundred copies to break even on it
i think that's what's been cool about
daily stokens on the products we've done
is is you're playing at a smaller scale
so you're able to make something much
more niche
but therefore much more valuable in some
ways because it doesn't have to please
everyone and it doesn't have to be
palatable
for a mass audience yeah i mean that's
been the really refreshing
aspect of this latest book i mean i
think
when you put a book out and you know
this as well as anyone there's a sort of
perversion that occurs like it has to
you know the the pre-order campaign has
to you know you guys sell those books in
the pre-order window because that's what
dictates
book seller or you know orders and all
of these lists that we put all this
[ __ ] importance on and
so much of it is [ __ ] and that
system is gamed
so often by people who have means
that it's that's become meaningless and
with this book to opt out of all of that
is so refreshing it's like yes pre-order
order like i don't care like and
i'm not trying to sell this book to a
billion people like i just want to get
it to the people who
care about what i'm doing and i'm super
awesome with that
it doesn't have to be anything beyond
that and to kind of
let go of those expectations or that i
should say the pressure that you place
upon yourself as an
author and how you know the book is
going to be not only received but
perceived by you know the ecosystem
that cares about publishing to just opt
out of that completely
has been you know really nice well you
brought up the social dilemma earlier i
thought it was
you know a couple months ago instagram
made that decision to take away
likes from from posts um although
weirdly
for us like people with the blue check
they didn't do it so we're still
we're still suffering uh for the under
the tyranny of the numbers but
i think one of the things that i found
about like doing the leather bound
edition or doing the other products that
we sold is that
because like you're handling the
business side of it and it's not public
a lot of the vanity comes away because
you're you like
it's like when you put when i put this
up on youtube i'm gonna see how many
views it does
and because i can see how many views it
does naturally you want it to be as many
as possible
but if it was a private video or or
somehow a site that didn't track
views that thought would never occur to
you and you would only think
is this good uh have the people that i
showed it to
said that they appreciated it yes or no
and
in a weird way podcasts are the same way
although there are download numbers for
podcasts i wonder if one of the
reasons the medium has thrived is that
nobody really knows how anyone else is
doing
and and the numbers are so delayed
and not public you're not like tracking
it you're just like was it a good
episode or not
yeah that's been really refreshing i
mean there are algorithms and like you
know
rankings and all that kind of stuff but
they can't even agree upon
you know what a listen is yes this whole
war going on in podcasting about you
know
what constitutes a a download or a
stream
so there isn't even any agreement which
is kind of nice too
because yeah well i don't want to care
about that all i want to do
is try to have a present authentic
experience make it as
good as i can and then i put it on the
internet but i put mine up on youtube
too
so not only are you seeing that and you
then you know wanted to you know be a
certain way or you want it to have you
know you want it to get traction
everybody else can see it right right
you're making that decision
about your inherent value based upon the
amount of attention that you're getting
and i think that that's
you know uh it's it's really damaging
to culture yeah it's a it's inherently
corruptive it's like you put a number on
it and it suddenly becomes
less good like i just imagine because
this is where i thought we'd wrap up is
i was thinking about your idea of like
a sort of a book about these
conversations it's like the greatest
conversationalist in history is socrates
imagine what socrates's conversations
would have been if you also had this
other eye towards how they're performing
well that would require application of
the stoic principles to
divorce yourself from caring about that
kind of stuff right right
all human beings and you know it's it's
almost refreshing to hear you say
that you you know struggle you know with
how to
interact with this attention economy and
do it in a healthy way
i kind of have just an abstinence policy
about it where it's like
most of the numbers are just kept from
me in one form or another
and so i don't know and then i think
it's like whenever you make a habit of
checking that's when you get into
trouble there used to be a website
called
novel rank and you would put in the isbn
of your book
and it would tell you not just how it's
doing in the us
but all the different translations on
all the different amazons at the same
time
and maybe like five years ago it closed
like the guy who made the website closed
and i swear this guy gave me like
cumulatively hours
days of my life back because now that it
doesn't exist
that energy goes somewhere else i can't
check it anymore
yeah you're much better off right of
course yeah
it's difficult man you know i i think
that uh
i have found myself i wouldn't say
editing myself but more self-conscious
in podcasts over maybe the last six
months
than i ever remember
asked and i don't know whether that's
a function of this hair trigger climate
that we're in right now
this fear of like i don't want you know
i don't want to say the thing that's
going to make people mad
and i think it tracks back to um
this uh fear
around audience reaction sure
and you know the work that i'm doing
right now is to completely
divorce myself from all comments like i
don't want
any of that interfering with my thought
process like i want to be able to speak
authentically i want to be able to speak
with conviction
and i can't the minute i start thinking
about like how is this going to land
with a certain individual
your history right like the whole value
of what i'm trying to do
becomes denigrated as a result of that
process and i think it's because of this
infection of of vitriol and
acrimony that is making you know nuanced
conversations so difficult right now
like all you have to do is look at
your comment section or what people say
in response to whatever sam harris
decides to tweet that day or anything
like that and you realize like
it's it's a it's really a sewer out
there and that stuff will mess with you
psychologically
if you're not really careful and create
healthy boundaries around it
no i think you've got to put boundaries
there for me the boundary i have to work
on more
and be curious what you think is it's
like if i like let's say i do look at
the numbers for something
usually i'm just pretty pleased i'm like
oh wow people care this is great
it's it's when you then it's when those
numbers are relative to someone else
that's when you get in trouble
so it's like uh if you look and you're
like oh hey
you know 200 000 people listen to this
interview you're like that's amazing i
would have killed for that
five years ago the problem is then you
then you see
in the rankings somebody else did two
hundred thousand and one
and now all of a sudden it's not good
enough right and so i think
i think as a competitive person
one of the things you almost have to do
in creative pursuits
is almost put those like horse blinders
on so you don't actually
know who and what you're competing with
because it doesn't take you to a good
place
no it never does and it never ends
either and it doesn't matter how well
you do because somebody else
is out there doing better and you will
continually be
measuring yourself up against that
individual on this habit trail like i
think i've heard you talk about this
maybe it was with james altucher about
the
like the forbes list right like yeah
these billionaires who just you know
couldn't possibly spend all the money
that they have
you know get irate when one individual
is above them and the top 10
you know richest people in the world
like it's utter insanity
and it's you know that makes for an easy
example to illustrate how preposterous
the whole thing is but then we
have to reflect back on ourselves and
realize that we're all doing some
version of that
yeah right it doesn't matter if you're
in the one percent or the 0.01
or the 10 you're you're judging yourself
compared to the other people and there's
that there's that theodore roosevelt
quote that comparison is the thief of
joy
which i think is about as beautifully as
it could possibly be expressed
yeah and also the the the enemy
of of creative expression sure
doing it from a place of trying to
measure up against someone else other
than
from you know a purity of heart it's not
going to be good
anyway right it's i think about it is
are you doing it from a place of still a
fullness or a place of emptiness
and the fullness is where you want to be
coming from the sense of enough
and in order to do that you have to live
your life which means you got to put the
phone down
yes exactly rich thanks so much this was
amazing
thank you i appreciate it thanks ryan